I can't believe I just sold the mystery
machine
Freddy no one said it would be easy to
retire it sure looks easy for those two
this is the life Scoob no more mysteries
no more ghosts a crystal ball must come
at once to catch you I guess we've got
some unfinished business after all
well at least we've got 12 up the ghost
one is still on the loose I have to get
to the Himalayas to find the chest of
demons before he does
hold the phone you mean ghosts are you
talking about ghosts I'm talking about
goblins ghouls and geets galore there is
no such thing as ghosts
we're back in business what are you two
wearing not nearly enough oh hang on
gang I think Thelma just had our first
real ghost encounter
[Music]
did you hear something
that's just Scooby's stomachs he hasn't
eaten anything in over seven minutes
you've got to be kidding me scooby-doo
and the curse of the 13th ghost let's
catch some ghosts it's busting time his
day has really taken a turn look for it
on digital and DVD